Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart?
Yes?
Have you got my voice?
Hello, how are you?
Okay, so can you continue to hear me?
Okay, so let's begin then with our prayer before reading and studying.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose
of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother
Mary and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine, will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never
swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure.
And that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch
my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truth and the good that are in these writings and prayers, Amen.
Now I want to take up in April the 26th, 1925, we're going to have some wonderful messages
tonight.
Well, all the messages are wonderful.
I always feel that the ones we're actually doing are extremely special, but we're going
to be doing rounds and everything tonight to be fantastic.
So Louisa said, I was thinking to myself about certain things regarding the will of God,
which Jesus had told me and which had been put out for printing.
And therefore to go around through the hands of those who wanted to read them, I felt such
shame within me that this caused me an indescribable pain.
But when she uses the word shame, she's not actually using the word as we use it.
Shame is an experience that a person has after sin.
And it's the soul itself condemning you for this kind of action.
And so when that word is used, you mustn't take it in that sense.
Louisa is saying that she feels humiliated, she feels that her inner life is being exposed
to others.
And since she is living such a private life, just between herself and the Lord, the idea
that strangers that she would have absolutely no way of knowing if they were in the grace
of God or not, that they would be reading this stuff, just absolutely horrified her.
So I think when you read, I felt such shame, I think you should read, I felt such horror.
So I felt such horror within me that this caused me indescribable pain.
And I said, my beloved good, how could you allow this?
Because nothing can happen if God doesn't allow it.
My secrets, she said, which I wrote only to obey and only for love of you.
Now notice that the two very clear motivations in Louisa's life.
One is for love of Jesus and the other is obedience.
I wrote them only to obey and for love of you.
They're now coming before the eyes of others.
And so this is the horror any of us would experience in your absolutely private affairs
being dangled out in the public square.
And if they continue publishing more things, I will die of horror and pain, notice I'm
putting horror in there and after all this, as recompense from my heart, sacrifice, you've
left me very painfully.
Had you been with me, you would have had pity on my pain and you would have given me the
strength.
Now beside that, I want you to put two Corinthians 12, nine, my power works best in weakness.
You might wonder why the Lord chooses weak people and people who are not in a position
of power is that he works best with people who need to depend on him completely.
And he has said this over and over in these volumes that he wants us actually turning
to him for everything and he wants us leaning on him for everything.
You heard Greg say that last night that the Lord has brought him to depend on him for
absolutely every Iota.
So the Lord actually wants that and he wants to bring each one of us to it.
But Louisa said, while I was thinking of this, my sweet Jesus came out from within my interior,
which means the kingdom of God is within Luke 17 21 and placing one hand on my forehead
and the other on my mouth.
Now we've had this a couple of times and it always makes me laugh because Jesus is trying
to get her to stop talking and just begin to perceive at a much deeper level what's actually
going on as they're wanting to stop the many afflicting thoughts that came to me.
He told me be quiet, telling an Italian to stop talking is very difficult.
I know I have led Italians in silent retreats and the first time I ever suggested that they
just laugh their heads off at the idea of keeping silent for six days.
And then I put them on training for the retreat by bringing them away for a silent weekend.
And they whispered the whole weekend and then they said to me on the Sunday, "Oh, we kept
quiet."
I said, "You did, you whispered away and you communicated all the time and you kept talking.
It was just a lower tone."
And then they began to realize that when I said stop talking, it means it.
And so Jesus is trying to get her to actually be quiet interiorly.
Now if we become quiet interiorly, we will hear God.
If we do not become quiet interiorly, we will only hear our own conflicting emotions and
we will hear the raucous noises of the world where we won't hear God.
So he said be quiet.
Do not want to continue any further.
Now instead of the word want, I'm putting the word choose because he's emphasizing the
will, everything's in the will.
Do not choose to continue any further.
These are not your things but mine.
This whole revelation about the coming of the kingdom of the divine will is actually
the Lord's business.
Louisa is just the person that he has chosen to work through because he has to work through
somebody.
It is my will, he said, that wants to follow its course to make itself known.
Now the kingdom of the divine will cannot take off on the earth unless it is known.
So I've been emphasizing to people from the time I came into the divine will mission that
we have got to tell other people we've got to keep proclaiming it.
Otherwise how will anybody know?
It is my will that wants to follow its course to make itself known and my will is more than
the sun and it takes too much to hide the light of the sun.
He's referring gently to Matthew chapter 5 verses 14 to 17 where Jesus says you are the
light of the world you cannot hide this light under a bushel.
If you do then you are absolutely denying the call that God has actually given to you
but he says that his will is greater than the sun and who could even attempt to hide
the sun under a bushel.
It's completely impossible he said.
If they stop it on one side it surpasses the obstacle which they've placed in it and squeezing
through the other sides it follows its way with majesty leaving those who wanted to prevent
its course confused.
One of the lovely things we all witness when we get up in the mornings is that the light
has managed to get round the curtains or the blinds that you have put on your windows and
it just doesn't accept the blockage it will come in anyway and so Jesus said a lamp can
be hidden but the sun no never and the sun is the divine will you see the image of the
divine will such is my will it is more than the sun and if you as a small creature on
the planet and he has told her before she's only an atom but for those of you who haven't
been listening to me all the time for us to be called an atom is actually a great complement
because if you look at the model of the universe and for some reason or other they say it's
the shape of an egg I don't know the reasoning for that but if you look at this model of
the universe if you look for the Milky Way it's only a tiny speck in the entire universe
and if you home in with your machines into the Milky Way and multiply it at millions
of times so that you can get to the point of seeing it then go looking for the solar
system and it's a speck in the Milky Way.
So the little planet we live on is a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe so to
be called an atom is something great I suppose if Louisa had a more physics he would have
used the image of one of the tiny little things inside of the atom but he calls her an atom
which I think is a complement.
How could you possibly hide the sun that is giving light to that whole solar system is
absolutely impossible.
Therefore be quiet my daughter he said and let the eternal sun of my will follow its
course whether it's through the writings watch this now because we're living in the
age where this must actually be done whether it's through writings or through print or
through your words which is what I'm doing right at this moment or through your manners
we don't use that word nowadays through your ways through your lifestyle so the divine
will is proclaimed through the volumes that's the print through trying to proclaim it and
teaching others in our classes and through our lifestyle now last night you heard Greg
underlining for all of us the importance of the lifestyle proclaiming to everybody who
we are but this is the way you proclaim it but it must be proclaimed.
Let the divine will escape like the light he says let it cover the whole world that's
what he wants I long for it I want it now when God says I wanted that is an absolutely
extraordinary statement for those of you who for those of you who may have read the writings
of Maria Valtorta who was given an extraordinary revelation about the public life of Jesus
apart from other parts of his life and it was given at the same time as he was talking
to Louisa and there's an extraordinary overlap between the two sets of writings only those
who have read Louisa and read Maria can see the overlap and sometimes when I have been
in need of an explanation of something in Louisa's writings I found the explanation in Maria
Valtorta is fascinating what I want to underline is that in Maria's writings when Jesus wanted
to work a miracle what he said was I wanted that was that what God says I wanted it will
come into being and that's that it doesn't matter who opposes it so here is the same
Jesus saying that he wants the divine will to spread throughout the earth and to take
over the whole of humanity and besides how much really of the truth of my will was put
out of course they don't put out the first few volumes and the first few volumes are
the introduction to the later volumes so he said it was just atoms so they're the early
volumes of its light because as you know the first four volumes are the foundation of this
revelation that God has given to us volumes 5 to 10 are sort of building the walls 11
and 12 is putting the roof on and the rest of the volumes are actually turning it into
a living space taking all that was said in volumes 1 to 10 deepening it widening it explaining
it putting it into a new context and so on so that we were grasped and you have a consummate
teacher there who knows how to go back to the same point and make sure that it is said
from a slightly different angle that if you didn't get it the last time you'll get it
the next time so all of us who are trained teachers can see this wonderful pedagogy in
the writings of Louisa so he said the thing that was only put out were just atoms so initially
they put out volumes 1 to 10 and even though atoms still if you knew what good they do
in other words they're introducing people into the divine will what will happen then
after all the truths that I have spoken to you about my will will have been gathered
together the fecundity of its light the good it contains all united together will form
not just the atoms of the rising sun but the full midday itself now you and I have the
privilege that we have the full revelation in front of us what good will this eternal
sun not produce in the midst of creatures because all Jesus keeps on using the image
of the sun and all you need is for the sun to beam its light and its heat down upon the
earth and the earth becomes extraordinarily productive so he's saying that when this
revelation is exposed to the human race it will become spiritually extraordinarily productive
and you and I will be happier Jesus said in seeing my will known loved and fulfilled
therefore he said let me do and then no it's not true that I have left you he's forever
defending himself on this particular point Luisa keeps on telling you you've left me
and we read ad nauseam that he comes out from within her her her being so he's inside all
the time so he has to defend himself it's not true that I've left you how can you say
that don't you feel me within you don't you hear the echo of my prayer in your interior
as I embrace everything letting no one escape me since all things and all generations are
like one single point for me this is why it's so easy for us to pray for all souls past
present and future because we take them into that singularity that is the divine will and
there's neither past nor future in it everything is present everything is now everything is
active everything is available to us but I want to give you Hebrews 725 there because
the author of Hebrews tells us that Jesus lives forever to make intercession for us that
he's working very hard for us in heaven to try and bring us to the place where we can
cooperate fully with God and his presence in Luisa is so strong that he says to her now
you have to admit the truth you actually not only feel me present but you actually hear
me praying that's in the most extraordinary union with God it must have been an absolutely
amazing experience not too many people are at that depth he says I bring all generations
they're like one single point for me and for all I pray love adore and repair and that's
what he wants us to enter into to join him to do all of this for the human race now one
of the things that has come to me you might have a deeper insight is that if you have
a family member who's either old and frail or they have some major disability of body
or mind that you will do things for that person who cannot do them themselves and if you look
out at the people around us on the earth they are spiritually blind deaf and dumb so they
can't see here or understand or pray correctly and what the Lord does with us who do see here
and understand and know the issues he asks us to do for them what you would do for a blind
person a deaf person a dumb person a lame person a sick person a dying person I think
it's fantastic it's pure love and he does it for us all the time blessed mother does
it for us all the time Luisa does it and he asks us to do it as well for all the others
so when it comes to the day of judgment people on the earth who have not known God or who
have absolutely rejected religion and so on will be utterly amazed to discover that people
they never heard of did all the praying for them and all the repairing and all the rest
of it and they get to heaven because of us it's a great privilege and Jesus goes on and
he says to Luisa and you echoing my prayer that's what we're doing you feel as if you
are holding everyone and everything in your power and you repeat what I do is it perhaps
you who does this or your capacity John 15 5 I want to give you there without me you can
do nothing but I also want to give you Philippians 4 13 I can do all things in Christ who gives
me the strength and oh he said it is I who are present in you and it is my will that makes
you hold everyone and everything as though in your power this is the divine will operating
within us and the divine will follows its own course within your soul and then do you
want anything apart from my will he said and of course with Luisa the answer was absolutely
no I'd have to leave it to you to give your answer because if your answer is no I want
nothing but the divine will then he says what you have to fear the divine will gives you
everything would you fear that I might leave you it's not actually possible because the
divine will is the essence of God don't you know that the surest sign this is very important
if you have your note your no volumes with you you should really put VIP beside this don't
you know that the surest sign that I reside within you is that my will has its place of
honor in you that's number one secondly that it dominates you thirdly that it does with
you whatever it wants now there's the position that we were talking about last night of complete
and total surrender to the divine will so that God is in fact reigning in us and his will
is being done on earth as it is in heaven that's why the VIP is very important there and then
he says my will and I are inseparable naturally because the divine will is the essence of God
and my will renders inseparable from me one who lets herself be dominated by it now in
the early volumes volumes one to ten you heard Jesus only speaking about his mother as my
inseparable mother from volume 12 we've heard him talk about my inseparable Louisa and now
he's talking to you and me and saying this is how you will become inseparable from me what
an incredible privilege my will and I are inseparable and my will renders inseparable
from me from me one who lets herself be dominated by it so there's the big thing we have to
give our consideration for so let's go on to the next text that is May the first 1925
and Jesus talks about three unique missions on the earth and these missions are not going
to be repeated one is his mission as redeemer the second is our blessed mother's mission
as coradema coradam tricks and the third one is Louisa her mission to introduce the divine
will so Louisa said I was thinking about the many things that my beloved Jesus had told
me on his holy will and some doubts arose within my soul which is not necessary to write
about here she obviously had another notebook and which she rose things like that to her
confessor I will only say what my highest good told me my daughter he said in certain
missions or offices such gifts graces riches and prerogatives must be enclosed within them
that if it wasn't for the mission or the office occupied it would not be necessary for one
to possess the whole magnitude of what one possesses there's a very important answer
to a question that people often ask what is the difference between Louisa and us what
is the difference between what she was asked to do and what we're asked to do and so Jesus
is going to explain the unique position that our blessed mother had vis-à-vis redemption
and the unique position that Louisa has vis-à-vis the divine will and we as followers of Jesus
we can enter into redemption and receive as much as we want but we don't have this office
and therefore the gifts and graces and prerogatives of that office are not necessary for us and
so it's actually very important to be able to answer that so the whole magnitude of the
gifts and the graces are given because given to him because of the necessity to carry out
that office okay let's take the first one and this is the Redeemer the office of Redeemer
okay the unique office is only one Redeemer my humanity Jesus said was given by my divinity
the mission of the salvation of souls and the office of Redeemer so he came on earth specifically
to redeem us now because of this office I was entrusted with their souls with there is all of us
with all the souls of all humanity with their pains and with their satisfactions
in other words Jesus had to make reparation for everyone so if this is your personal copy
write reparation over satisfactions so he said I enclosed everything and if my humanity had not
enclosed just one soul one pain one satisfaction the office of Redeemer would not have been complete
now what he's saying is if I left out one Iota my office would not have been complete
this office had to include every soul from Adam to Zachary everyone who would ever come to live
on this planet whether they believed in him or not so he said if I didn't do that my office would
not have been complete I would not have been closed within myself all the graces all the goods
and all the light that was necessary to be given to each soul now look at that again and look at
it slowly he was given the light that was necessary for every single soul everything that you and I
actually need Jesus has it you only need to ask we're very much in the position of small children
in a family and they don't have to worry about who brings in the living wage they don't have to
worry about the mortgage they don't have to worry about repairing the house and all of this kind of
stuff all they do is they ask and Jesus gave us this in the gospel ask and you will receive
seek and you will find knock and the door will be opened unto you that's Luke chapter 11 so since
everything that I need and everything that you need and everything that everybody else needs
to go to heaven is in Jesus all we've got to do is go to him
he's made it as simple as possible and then he said even though not all souls are saved and that's a
very important statement not all souls are saved because the human race has free will and so you
can offer a gift to a person and they can refuse to take it you can offer an opportunity for a person
to do something and they may not accept it it's the human will that decides whether in fact we will
be saved or not because Jesus has done his entire office of redeemer so even though not all souls
are saved this says nothing I was to enclose the goods of all so that on my part I might have the
necessary and super abundant graces for every soul in order to be able to save all if they wanted
this was befitting to me for the decorum and the just honor of my office as redeemer
the same happens to the sun in the sky it contains so much light as to be able to give light to
everything on the planet and even if everybody doesn't actually enjoy the light that's because
of their own decision if the sun is shining outside and I sit in a dark room that says nothing about
the sun it says a lot about me if though everyone doesn't enjoy its light because of its unique
office which the sun has it possesses even that light which the creatures refuse and Jesus
possesses in himself all the graces that people refuse as well if this was befitting to the sun
because it was created by God as the unique sphere which was to warm the earth and embrace it with
its light in fact when one thing or one office is unique in order to be able to carry out its
office it is necessary for it to contain so much of that good as to be able to give it to all
in other words you have to be filled with so much grace so much gift so much of everything that you
have more than enough Jesus could have redeemed entire worlds not just planet earth and it wouldn't
exhaust even one atom of what he had so there's no limit to what we can ask the Lord to give us
because it doesn't matter how much we ask him to give to us and to humanity and in the divine
will of course we're asking for everything for everybody else it doesn't matter how much you ask
because it will never ever deplete the extraordinary amount of grace and glory that's there
how much more befitting was it to me who is was to be the new sun of souls and who was to give light
to everyone now one John one five God is light John eight twelve and John nine five Jesus says
I am the light of the world in other words I am the one that must give light to everybody
that's exactly what he's saying here so I was the one to give light to all and to embrace everything
with my light to be able to bring them to the supreme majesty and offer to it an act which would
contain all acts and make super abundant light descend upon all in order to place them all in
safety so Jesus has provided enough light enough grace enough redemption for every single soul
from Adam to Zachary to be saved now we go to the second case and the second case is the
office of the mother of God the coredemptrix also a unique office which can't be shared with
anybody else in addition to myself there's my celestial mother who was given the unique mission
of mother of the son of God and the office of coredemptrix of mankind now notice that Jesus
underlining the teaching about the coredemptrix here for her mission of the divine maternity she
was enriched with so much grace that all that belongs to all the other creatures both celestial
and terrestrial united together would never be able to equal her i think that's why louise
in referring to her speaks of the height the summit of grace okay so mare means a sea
she was a sea of grace maria but even this wasn't enough jesus said to draw the word
down from heaven into her maternal womb she embraced all creatures she loved she repaired she
adored the supreme majesty for everyone in such a way as to accomplish by herself all that the
human race generations owed to god now our blessed mother living the only person on earth living in
the divine will from conception to death that she actually did all the adoration and praise
and reparation and everything for all of us that's one of the one of the many many reasons why
we need to be very close and loving towards her she has done all of this for us and for everyone
else as well so in her virginal heart she had an inexhaustible vein of love understood towards god
and towards other creatures because the perfection of the law is that you shall
deuteronomy six four to ten you shall love the lord your god with all your heart
with all your soul with all your mind and with all your being and you shall love your neighbor
as yourself jesus said in matthew twenty five i think it is he said these two laws
summarize the entire bible to love god and to love your neighbor so here jesus is saying in one sentence
that our blessed mother loved god and loved all human beings perfectly in the divine will when the
divinity found in this virgin the requital of the love of all the divine will felt enraptured
or the divinity felt enraptured and formed in her its conception now notice all of this has
been done because mary was about fifteen by the time she conceived the son of god so she had fifteen
full years plus the nine months in her mother's womb to do all of this work
and as she conceived me she took on the office of co-redentrics
and she took part in and embraced together with me all the pains all the satisfactions
all the reparations and the maternal love towards all now this is exactly what we have to enter into
at our little level because we're not in these unique offices and so we are allowed to participate
and i see that participation in a very simple way one of the things that struck me very deeply
when i lived in africa was that everybody in the family had to participate everybody it doesn't
matter how young you are and i was actually present when a mother took her newborn in her arms
and she had the pot there cooking the main meal and she took the infant's hand and put it on the
spoon and she herself moved around the pot carrying the infant in her arms but that child
with the mother's help moved that spoon once everybody participates
another time i remember being very very deeply touched by this
is the offer tree when people make their offerings to the church uh we do it in an awful way of just
passing a bag around the place but where i was living in africa the people processed up to the
altar and gave their offerings to god and it was done publicly and sometimes they had nothing to
offer except a little bit of vegetation or something but they went and one day i was behind a young
woman with a baby on her back and the baby seemed to me to be over a year old and so the mother had
to stand very erect and from the height she dropped the widow's might into the basket and i thought
yeah there's the widow's might the lord will be very pleased and as soon as she did the child
moved around her shoulder and said to the mother make i put them in other words is it my turn
and the mother smiled and she bent over so that the child could bend over the basket and from the
height came another tiny little coin from that tiny child who knew that if we are participating
in this great sacrifice i must take part i must do my part so um i see our mission in the divine will
like that that while jesus and mary have done everything that we're allowed to stir the part a
little bit and we're allowed to put our little widows might in and just give it with as much love as
as possible in the divine will and that's the way i i see it maybe you see it differently in the heart
of my mother jesus said there was a fiber of maternal love towards each single person every
single individual the divine will makes this actually possible uh for somebody living at this
depth it's really fantastic so this is why he said when i was on the cross in truth and with justice
i declared her the mother of all that's john 1927 she ran together with me in the love in the
pains in everything she never left me alone in the eternal one if the eternal one had not
placed so much grace in her as to be able to receive the love of everyone from her alone you see this
unique office that the love of every creature was to be offered to him through her he would never
have moved from heaven to come to the earth to redeem mankind here is the necessity to be fitting
this that having the mission of mother of the word she embrace and surpass everything because
her mission was totally unique above and beyond no wonder we've seen that you're the glory of
Jerusalem the joy of israel in the honor of our people so jesus says when an office is unique
it comes as a consequence that one must let nothing escape him one must have everything under one's
eyes so as to be able to hold out that good which one possesses one must be like a true sun
which can hold out light to everyone and that's the way it was for me and for your celestial mother
and my celestial mother so having then explained the unique role and office of the redeemer and the
unique role of the office of the redemptrix we now come to the unique role of louisa and this
explanation was very badly needed by the priests who were guiding louisa so that they could take it
to the bishops and into the hierarchy to explain what was actually going on otherwise they would
have misunderstood louisa as claiming an awful lot for herself and they wouldn't have understood
what god was actually saying so now your mission louisa's unique mission on repeatable okay your
mission of making the eternal will known is braided with mine and with that of my dear mother that
means they all link they're all part of this divine will and they're all stages of god bringing
the human race back to himself i don't know if you do jigsaw puzzles i do them when i want to relact
people think i'm crazy i do a difficult puzzle to me to relact you know but i look at it and i say
lord this is what you're doing in the human race you get this confounded mess and you turn it
into something beautiful you put art around it and you turn it into something beautiful
and that's what he's doing all the time and it had to be done in stages so that it could be accomplished
so but louisa's one had to come last because the others had to come in time before it and since
it is to serve the good of all louisa's offices to serve the good of all it was necessary to
centralize the very sun of my volition in one creature so that as a unique mission this sun
might let its rays blaze from just one person so that all might take the good of its light
so he says to louisa if i have given you the unique office of opening up the third fiat
opening up the kingdom of the divine will it absolutely had to be that the divine will would be
planted inside of you in its fullness insofar as a creature can actually take it it had to be
therefore for the decorum and honor of my will i was to pour into you such graces light love and
knowledge of the divine will as the herald and the preparation which be fitted the dwelling of the
sun of my volition even more you must know just as my humanity because of its office of redeemer
conceived all souls in the same way because if your office of making my will known and raining
on the earth as you keep doing your acts in my will for everyone all creatures remain conceived
in your will this is hardly comprehensible to us who have too much flesh and not enough spirit if
i can put it that way and that is that all the the work that louisa was asked to do
was to enable all of us to be able to come after her and enter into the divine will if he hadn't
accomplished all of that in one person who had been born with original sin like the rest of the
human race at the rest of us couldn't have followed and he explains elsewhere that he had to choose
somebody who had been born with the original sin otherwise the rest of us would have had the
excuse look we can't be like your mother because she was conceived without original sin therefore
she's in a different place to us all together and since you were god and man then you're in a different
place all together so he had to choose somebody and he had to prove to us that he could take somebody
who was born with original sin and bring them to such a union with him that all of that would be
wiped out they would be brought back to their origin where adam had left off when he sinned
and that the divine will could take place on the earth so he says as you're doing your acts
in my will all creatures remain conceived in your will and as you keep repeating your acts in my
will you form so many sips of life of the divine will to be able to nourish all the creatures
which by virtue of my will are as though conceived in yours the lord made it possible for louisa
to open up her will in such a way that he could implant in it through her acts all that he wanted
for the future louisa wouldn't have felt all other souls being conceived in her will it's
that's that's that's that's on a completely spiritual dimension
do you not feel how in my will you embrace everyone from the first to the last creature that was to
exist on the earth well it's perfectly obvious from the prayers of louisa that we read in her
volumes that she does in fact embrace everyone and you and i who have been called to live our part
in this mission we find that you absolutely have to it there's something in you it is the divine
will saying no no no you can't just do that for one or two people you must include everybody from
adam to sakari in fact it's one of the things i love about the divine will it that you embrace
the whole of humanity i think it's fantastic and therefore so many millions of people will be saved
and the shock will be how they got saved and that's because all their acts were done further
and their reparation was done for them and their their soul healing was done for them everything was
done for them by people that they didn't know and then we have the immense privilege of realizing
that we had our little top and safety part in this entire mission as well so do not feel he said how
in my will you embrace everyone from the first to the last creature which is to exist upon the earth
and for all you would want to satisfy love please this supreme will binding it to everyone
removing all obstacles that prevent its dominion within creatures making it known to all there's
our mission in our own little space and you expose yourself even with pains to satisfy this supreme
will for all which so much loves to make itself known and to reign in the midst of creatures
to you first born of the first born daughter of the divine volition it is given to make known
the qualities the value and the good it contains and the next bit is extremely important
you also have to communicate the eternal sorrow that the divine will has in living unknown
and hidden in the midst of the human generations
only human beings could give God that kind of sorrow because human beings are the only
ones among God's creatures who were given the freedom to say no and boy do we know how to say no
and so we've given God this eternal sorrow his divine will is in us otherwise we would disintegrate
his divine will is in everything otherwise they would disintegrate and yet he lives
unknown among us I also say that about Jesus in the Eucharist while he is personally present body
soul and divinity present I mean who among Christians realize that the Lord is there
our behavior says we don't realize it our behavior says we don't really believe it he's also living
in plain sight but completely hidden as well in great sorrow and he explains that to Louisa as well
so you've to make known the the eternal sorrow of the divine will of living
unknown and hidden in the midst of the human generations even more not just hidden what despised
and offended by the evil and placed by the good at the level of the other virtues okay
so here you've got the human race divided into good and evil so the ones who have rejected God
utterly despised the idea that God is in our midst and God's looking after everything and we
rely on him for everything they tell you to grow up but the good people can bring the Lord down
to a human level which absolutely takes away from from the enormity of the grace that is given
I mean if you take the casualness with which people receive Holy Communion you'll get some idea
it's amazing and we think that we have done good by going to church and receiving Holy Communion
in other words we're better than other people because we go to church and we receive Holy Communion
it could be the exact opposite that knowing who it is that we receive that we do not give
the adoration and praise and everything that is required for him so both the good and the evil
on the earth offend the Lord and treat the divine will presence as if it was just a little lamp
and not the song so let's come to the next paragraph the mission of my will is the greatest
that can exist if you're using your book would you please color that in case you're ever tempted
to go off and do something else there is no good which does not descend from the divine will
there's no glory which does not come from the divine will heaven and earth everything is centered
in the divine will because the divine will is the essence of God therefore be attentive and do not
choose to waste time or we can waste time we can turn to other things everything I have told you
for this mission of my will was necessary not for you but for the honor the glory the knowledge
and the sanctity of the divine will the next bit I have to turn into English for you since I have
only one will okay there had to be one creature to whom I would entrust it and through whom I would
make its glory blaze for the rest of all whoever translated this stuff didn't understand English
okay so let's come to may the fourth at 1925 again we're talking about the mission of the divine will
and notice it says that it veils the mystery of the most holy trinity on the earth now if you
haven't read this before but I know you probably have you might say to yourself oh how is the blessed
trinity veiled in this you're going to find its the mission of Jesus the mission of Mary and the
mission of Louisa veiling this incredible mystery on the earth so after writing what is written above
Louisa said I began to do adoration to my crucified Jesus fusing all of myself in his most holy will
and my beloved Jesus came out from within my interior and placing his most holy face close to mine
all tenderness he said my daughter did you write everything I love this this wonderful relationship
on the mission of my will and Louisa yes yes of course I wrote everything he said what have I
told you you haven't written everything in fact he said you left out the most essential thing I
I just I just love this dialogue between Jesus and Louisa this is a bit like a nice teacher saying
to a student did you include all the facts in that text you know and say oh yeah yeah yeah I've
done it and said are you sure well the most important bit you left out
Jesus said you've left out the most essential thing so continue writing he said and I want you to add
and this is VIP the mission of my will will veil the most holy trinity upon the earth
just as in heaven there's the father the son and the holy spirit inseparable from one another
but distinct among themselves forming the whole beatitude of heaven in the same way on earth there
will be three persons who because of their missions you see when we've been talking about the three
missions will be distinct and inseparable from themselves there is the virgin with her maternity
which veils the paternity of the father is that wonderful and in closes the father's power
in order to fulfill her mission of as mother of the eternal word and co-redemptrix of humanity
now you weren't expecting him to put her first but it's the eternal paternity of God that he is
putting first secondly there's my humanity for the mission of redeemer which enclosed the divinity
and the word without ever separating from the father and the holy spirit it manifested my
celestial wisdom adding the bond of rendering myself inseparable from my mother so you have
the power the word and then for louisa it's the divine love so in louisa you have the holy spirit
manifested this is very very important because i've come to realize that what the lord is talking
about in all of these volumes is that we're going to have the definitive descent of the holy spirit
the holy spirit is the love of god and we're going to have the definitive descent of the holy spirit
upon the church and the world as was prophesied in the prophet joel chapter three verses one to five
so you can either call it the definitive Pentecost the descent of the holy spirit or the new Jerusalem
or the new era of the divine will whatever it is it's all the same thing and the scriptures speak
about it just slightly from a slightly different angle so the third one is you Jesus said to louisa
for the mission of my will as the holy spirit will make a display of his love so there's the
fulfillment of joel chapter three verses one to five manifesting to you the secrets the
progetes of my will and the goods that the divine will contains to make happy those who will give
themselves to knowing how much good this supreme will contains and to love the divine will and to
let it rain in their midst offering their souls to let it dwell within their heart this is where we
come to the point where we want to consecrate ourselves i know that people pray they prayer
of consecration privately but to make a public consecration to the divine will is a different
statement altogether it's a statement to heaven it's a statement to earth and it's a statement to
the underworld we're declaring who we are and what mission we have accepted so we have to love the
divine will let it rain in our midst offering our souls to let it dwell within our hearts that the
divine will may be able to form its life in us adding the bond of inseparability between louisa
between blessed mother and the eternal word now if you're doing the book of revelation with me
when we come to chapter 19 of the book of revelation it will be the return of the eternal word his name
was known only to himself it was the word of god it's it's the descent of the word of god these three
missions are distinct and they're also inseparable the first two have prepared the graces the light
the work and the with unheard of pains for the third mission of my will now if jesus and mary had
not done all the preparation and the reparation and intercession and suffering and all the rest of
it the third fear couldn't come so this was all preparation for the third mission of my will
and to then fuse themselves all in it without leaving their office so as to find rest because
my will alone is celestial rest do you remember um Matthew 11 28 come to me and i will give you rest
do you remember that as only in the divine will that ultimately we find that rest
these missions will not be repeated they're unique
because the exuberance of grace light knowledge is such and so great in them that all human
generations can be filled with them even more they will not be able to hold all the good that
they contain now my book says contain at the beginning of that and that doesn't make sense
it will not be able to hold all the good that they contain okay these missions are symbolized
by the sun now here he's going to give us an example to try and get us to understand it
um in fact in creating the sun i filled it with so much light and heat that all human
generations have super abundant light so there's super abundant grace and redemption and everything
made ready for us nor did i consider that since the beginning of creation there was
only adam and eve who could enjoy it i could place the necessary light for them only
and then increase new light for the generations that would grow from them but he said no
i made the sun full of light from the beginning god provides a head of time for us
i made it full of light just as it is now and will be for the decorum and honor
of our power that's the father our wisdom that's the son and our love which is the holy spirit
our works are always done with the fullness of all the good that they will contain
the Lord does everything at the beginning
nor are they subject to increasing or decreasing now he has said that about the creation of the
universe as well that it was created complete and it will neither increase nor decrease even
though the scientists disagree with him and that's what i did in the sun he said i centralized in it
all the light that was to serve up to the last man on the planet but how much good does the sun not
do for the earth what glory in its mute light does it not give to its creator i can say that because
of the immense goods it does for the good that it does for the earth in its mute language the sun
glorifies me and makes me known more than all other things put together why is that because
every creature whether human or animal knows the sun everybody needs it everybody reacts to the sun
if the sun isn't shining brilliantly on as we say oh it's a terrible day if the sun is shining
brilliantly everybody's happy we all react very well i want to give you two sams to illustrate
the heavens declaring the glory of god and one is sam 19 verses one to six another one is sam 145
verses one to seven and the third one is sam 148 verses one to four the heavens glorify god
okay so the jesus said the sun glorifies me and makes me known more than all other things put
together and this because it is full in its light and stable in its course now that's what the lord
has been asking of louisa from the very beginning and through her he's asking that of us as well
that we would be stable in our relationship with god that we would be stable in our commitment to
the divine will and therefore that he can fill us more and more and more with his light and grace
when i looked at the sun which with so much light on the adam and eve were enjoying
i also looked at all the living see everything is present in the divine will that singularity
a single point he could see all the future generations and it must have been wonderful
for jesus on the cross with his dying eyes to actually see into the future and see all that was
going to happen i also looked at all the living he said and in seeing that that light was to serve
everyone my paternal goodness exalted with joy and i remained glorified in my works i did the same
with my mother i filled her with so much grace that she can give graces to all without ever
exhausting even one of them so don't be shy in asking you can't empty her cup it's not actually
possible i did the same with my humanity he said there's no good which it did not possess
it enclosed everything and it enclosed the very divinity to give my humanity to whoever actually
wanted it unfortunately we're living at a time when so many in the church and so many in the world
actually don't want jesus um so here we have a description of generosity and mercy without
borders there's no limit i did the same with you jesus said to luisa i enclosed my will in you
and with it i enclosed myself that is the possession of god that is union with god that you possess
god and he possesses you you and me and i and you both completely won that's john 14 20 and 21
john 14 20 21 so i enclosed its knowledge its secrets and its light in you i filled your soul
up to the brim so much so that what you write is nothing other than the outpouring of what you
contain in my will that is a very important statement that that needs a good a nice good red color
um that what you're actually expressing is what the divine will is trying to express through you
and even though it now serves you alone now is 1925 that the divine will serves you alone
and if you would limmers of light serve a few others in other words the priests who have been
affected and the sisters who came to know about it and and hannibal defrances to communities and so
on a few limmers of light serve a few others i'm content he said because being light
more than a second sun it will make its way by itself in order to illuminate the human
generations and to bring about the fulfillment of our works that our will be known that our will be
loved and that our will reign as life in creatures the divine will is in us anyway sustaining us in
being but to reign in us as life is a different matter all together this was the purpose of creation
he has been repeating that now uh quite a bit recently this is the beginning this is the means
and this is the end the divine will is it therefore he said be attentive because this is about placing
in safety the eternal will which with so much love wants to dwell among humanity so i want to give
you proverbs 8 31 that the lord delights to be with the children of men just like any parent delights
to be with their small children but the divine will wants to be known now he keeps repeating that
over and over again therefore uh spreading the volumes and knowledge of them is actually essential
and trying to help one another to come to understand it is actually essential as well
the divine will does not want to be like a stranger it wants to have its goods and to become the life
of each one however it also wants its rights you know it isn't just all candy it wants its place of
honor and it wants the human will to be put aside they really need to underline that one
the human will is the only enemy for the divine will and for man
notice the word only enemy we would have thought that satan was the big enemy and Jesus says no
satan wouldn't have a chance if the human will was given over to the divine will he would have
no chance at all of getting near us because satan cannot go near the divine will and therefore
we have to at some point come to really grasp the fact that the human will actually is the enemy
the mission of my will was the purpose of the creation of man he wanted the divine will to reign
in us my divinity did not depart from heaven from its throne while my will not only departed but
descended into all created things and formed its life in them so something that is very difficult
to explain while god remained in heaven yet the divine will was able to buy locate into all creatures
and all things upon the earth it descended into all created things and formed its life in them
and while all things recognized me and I dwell in them with majesty and decorum man alone drove me
away this is the we're hearing that so frequently but I want to conquer him I want to win him and
therefore my mission is not ended now there is the mystery of divine love what is it that about us
that god wants to actually conquer us and he he wants our surrender and not only does he want
our surrender and not only does he want to reign in us but he wants us to reign with him in heaven
I'm always asking myself what does he see in us
I want to conquer him I want to win him and therefore my mission is not ended so I called you
that's louisa interesting to you my own mission that you may place the one who drove me away
on the lap of my will so we have to somehow bring all creatures back onto the lap of the
divinity so that more and more and more of them will surrender their will to the divine will to let
god reign on the earth satan will have to get off the planet as soon as this happens he cannot
stay around with the divine will and therefore we have an enormous responsibility towards our
fellow human beings because if we know this then we have to be aware of the fact that they who cannot
see or hear or pray or understand that they will automatically be victims to satan if we do not
bring them to the lord and therefore the reparation that we do for them and the intercession for them
is a vital part of our mission and a vital part of our expressing our love both for god and for our
neighbor therefore do not be surprised at the many great and marvelous things that I may tell you
for the sake of this mission or at the many graces that I give you because this is not about making
a saint this is terribly terribly important before you came into the divine will we wanted to get
our soul saved and if possible become a saint and once you come into the divine will you drop all
that and you look after god's glory and you look after your neighbor and you forget about yourself
and your sanctity and all the rest of it and your throw yourself into the arms of the lord
I think that's such a liberation I think it's absolutely fantastic but it's one of the signs that
you will know that you have shifted into the divine will is that you let your own salvation
and your own sanctity in my case it would be an inverted commerce and all of that just let it go
start let's start an issue but what a wonderful thing it would be that if we arrive in god's
presence and we've done everything we could to give him glory and to make reparation for other
human beings so as many of them as possible would be saved I think that's fantastic
it's very liberating it's very wonderful it's not about making a saint he said or saving the
generations this is about making a divine will in safety he's saying to louise we have to bring the
generations onto the lord's lap yes but for louise it was to make a divine will in safety so that all
may return to the beginning you know the amazing thing is that spiritually going backwards is progress
in the world going forward is progress but we've got to go back to the beginning we've got to go
back to our origin and we've got a backtrack on a journey that we have taken and we have
got to go to the place where humanity stopped and we've got to start all over again from there
so going backwards is forward so this is this is about placing a divine will in safety
so that all may return to the beginning to the origin from which they all came that origin is
the divine will and that is the purpose of my will that the purpose of my will will have its
fulfillment then in other words the human race has got to go back to that point where we made this
terrible mess and we've got to take up from there now that is illustrated in so many people's lives
throughout history and that is that if a person really makes a horrible mess of their lives
then they have to backtrack they've got to retrace their steps
if a person has spent years being an alcoholic for example they have to really backtrack until they
get back to the point of being sober again and pick up their lives again we've got to go back to
the beginning so it's a quarter past eight we don't know whether we should stop because there's no
possibility of completing the next message which is a very long one so it might actually be better
to stop at this particular point I'm sorry we didn't get to the next run because louisa is doing all
the rounds and all the i love yous in the next one we would have it the next time is that okay
so i'll just finish by saying glory be to the father and to the son and to the holy spirit
as it was in the beginning is now and ever shall be world without end amen